once Syracuse commits and decided to try
the G late and T Park
rocking around look at that nice cut
terrific cut and really fine finish he
started a bunch of games last year for
the Thunder Jeff but absolutely Oh
defensive block by New Orleans Noel is
he denied porzingis the one-handed slams
you know fox highlights in the preseason
cuz this is a preseason highlight my
goodness you can see porzingis was going
up who's the least efficient shot
Grayson Allen guard makes the Grizzlies
pay
Adams looking a wee little wants to run
[Applause]
my own eyes I wouldn't say anything
Gallinari you know what that reminds me
the other night with Dennis shrewder at
the room in transition on stage so
Gorman and here's an inside
Lochner let's go on and he is so
terrific with those off the ball well
lots of fire scene this sequence quite a
bit this afternoon didn't hit the rim so
no he set up ahead
[Applause]
soaring to the rim why not get out in
the open court Diallo knows exactly how
to finish that good spacing by Gallo on
that played the knock down that shot the
deep and now sta with the steal
look out there's frozen down
[Applause]
of expecting the newest recipient of a
pass to take the shot and then every now
and then there's one special possession
how about this the hill bhajami
[Music]
part of an 8-0 run for the Thunder
digital Russell is on the bench dunk the
jet bike Chris and now we get a loose
ball foul in transition I mean the block
party is on how many times have you seen
him do this that is just beautiful boat
bitman high above the rim and he timed
that perfectly
he's got all ball up top that's tough to
do so Mike here in this fourth quarter
he down by 7 how do you races that the
ship they're just start another
ferocious
this comes out the set piece here the
balls moving and
Muskaan is a great job so you almost
would be Church in London and if hommies
is just you know he's winding up I don't
know what Robin Lopez was doing over
there
in the area for not least 91 he's taking
the shot that's way off in the Thunder
halftime here with under five seconds
Paul double-teamed heaves it from half
he got it to go sign it for me wow it
just did that as though I'm just you
know what I just made it three before I
know I'm further out my foots on the
half-court line but check this out it's
good and if you're the Thunder why not
go right back inside until they make the
adjustment but who is this guy here
there's a little high-low action so
petite oh no he didn't
yes he did aw come on he must have
talked some tank in the office just a
little bit of go-go juice to get you
going
[Applause]
well folks he had no chance to get that
and Rennick thought it was you know it
was a walk in the plant to pick your
spots and make it timely
[Music]
[Applause]
sit down with the two-handed stuff edge
relations again dude James Blaylock from
Shawnee you just won a $50 sonic gift
car thanks to this so launches it
coaches
[Applause]
first free-throw that's what allowed the
Thunder the tightest ballgame up would a
play like that and a great job but
Dennis ruder to fight off Jeff Teague I
mean you couldn't have you know that's a
play that you practice all the time and
NBA folks and you just say okay let's
just try it
the success rate very low but you gotta
try it anyway and clearly he had enough
time as he release that link down on the
defensive end his den red 22 points in
the first six minutes with the Thunder
five points in the last six minutes with
Stephen Adams
oh that is a Rocky Mountain dunk out of
a timeout for the start this quarter
Stephen Adams is to continue to
attention to that deficit
[Applause]
as he climbs the ladder for the
two-handed slam I'm a Gallinari
Chicago doesn't have a shop Locker so
you certainly feel like you can take
this to the rim well the only block away
[Applause]
it should count kids
thanks to this SGA at the buzzer and
another punch hole as he punishes the
ramp at this pass way how'd it get that
into space I was still a lot of meat
left on that ball on Steve Adams father
by Sharon Jackson junior popping the
pitcher you have to get above him like
that touch drives kicks back guys on the
floor kits stuck with donek and look how
you do it does a great job but keeping
it straight in front of him not allow in
the turn a corner
[Music]
oh he's telling himself I gotta stop him
now just stop the action oh yeah
so he cooked up pulled over to the bench
oh the left hand that Megan and what you
like about it
in the words of Shak you say listen are
you not entertained
Lakers this year well join with the
veteran player good steal by Steven
Adams anticipating that pass along with
the veteran and Danny Green who's out
tonight Ferguson leaves him for Steven
at thumbs wimpy authoritative slammer
and Alice knows exactly what to do with
it he hammers at home under way you're a
no place in for that rebound Simons
[Applause]
completely [ __ ] away situation here with
that defense right side tags to the road
anyway so ready spot Baisley that's
going to the basket this is a great
block by the way that's a weak side
block
it's tough to do if it's a player like
that
[Applause]
going end-to-end here after winning that
tip Steven Adams might as well be Joe
Montana way we've seen before if anybody
has an opportunity to know it check out
that museum is fantastic my goodness
with authority gets up and runs allowed
by planted space how about this what was
that there's another Thunder steal this
time it's Gallinari he goes behind the
back set set up for dort with the nice
slam and transition is the nick dienes
continues of all about gala noise
stepping into the passing lane the
Dodgers would be happy about that
eight
[Music]
while sent over two dorks wits a double
team goes up and throws it down this is
what to talk about how about this pace
this dork darts to the bucket and
flushes it well the more experience
still playing three years ago that
swatted away by Nerlens Noel he's made
an impact now the time will confer with
Secaucus but this is not a burden my
goodness
can't slow that down just thirteen join
made one earlier he's got another one
this one's from the corner is Luke doors
got his second three of the night guys
would do that sometimes that's called
your issue for there his backside and
Baisley we've seen him he's left-handed
but not afraid to go to the right
there's a great job just taking contact
split the defense bonus amount attempted
20 free throws here in this first half
[Music]
Stephen Adams just beyond the timeline
and SS is smooth and even a shimmy big
smiles all around as he was wide open
plenty of time counted and that's his
first May 3 of the cyst here is Paul
with four seconds left until three cuz
he knows it's a two-for-one and then he
waved to me lo Gallinari down san I've
got the matchup I want gets Paul Millsap
reacting to the cross then the between
something's come on SGA swings it back
out to the perimeter check this out the
first slam the Darius baby he likes that
as well
cp3
thumbs-up Gallinari goes all the way to
the basket like that had some Italian
flair on that reverse grasp that
offensive rebound white you got to this
he came out of nowhere looked at he he
was late getting there but his limp and
his ability to get up in the air on five
guys connected they're good friends
they're having fun that is serious
levitation about the 2019 slam dunk
champ amadou diallo eight and this one
wasn't
vadik on a sparkling night for the
Thunder 25 experiment bigger than meat
look out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the thunder now up i6
and the cute got around one went up for
the slave and got to you Rach by Noel at
the rim under quickly back down the
other way is from Nerlens Noel meeting
him at the apex know this is the garden
T something I've said guard party but
this here is the block party